chicago fire chicago med chicago pd and
for a while chicago justice
what's the story of all these shows why
are they all set in chicago
keep watching for the behind the scenes
details
over a decades-long career dick wolfe
had brought many shows to television
including hits like the law order
franchise in the early 2010s wolf
decided to shift his focus from cops to
big city firefighters
wolff contacted nbc and they soon
brought screenwriters michael brandt and
derek hoss on board to develop a pilot
though they had a number of big screen
hits to their credit including too fast
too furious and 310 to yuma they had
little experience in television but bran
told the hollywood reporter that lack of
experience is part of why they got hired
dick was looking to do something totally
different and they were looking for
feature writers wolff and nbc liked the
pilot and by 2012 chicago fire was in
production with a slot on nbc's
primetime schedule
the reason the first of many one chicago
shows was set in chicago is because it
was the perfect locale
according to brent a show about first
responders was too touchy for new york
because quote september 11th is still a
big subject there while los angeles
doesn't have enough weather to be
dramatic
chicago fire chicago pd and chicago med
are all connected sharing the same
fictional reality under the one chicago
umbrella
but characters from every show
frequently pop up in other seemingly
unrelated series as well as mastermind
dick wolf has created many shows that
all apparently take place in the same
universe
for example 2014 chicago fire and
chicago pd crossed past with law and
order svu it proved so successful that a
few months later all those shows crossed
paths again telling a story that was
initially supposed to be a two-part svu
episode and in 2017 one arson story
dominated episodes of chicago fire
chicago pd chicago med and the
short-lived chicago justice but the
legal element presided over by judge
daniel melnick a character from the
original law and order which had been
cancelled in 2010 before the one chicago
universe even existed the crossovers can
even transcend the gulf between networks
in 2020 cbs's fbi a dick wolf production
featured chicago pd character haley
upton teaming up with the fbi's agent
o.a in new york
actor anthony ferraris has played rescue
squad 3 truck driver tony on all three
major 1 chicago shows with over 100
episodes of chicago fire and cameos on
both chicago pd and chicago med
not only does his character share his
name he shares his profession too
ferraris is a native chicagoan and an
active firefighter in fact he wasn't
even a professional actor before he was
cast on chicago fire in 2012
so how did he land the job
well a friend was told by a
firefighter's union that the show was
looking for extras and he asked ferraris
to accompany him on the audition
after he got the gig his involvement
increased on the first day of shooting
the crew discovered that none of the
actors cast as firefighters could drive
the emergency vehicles ferrara said the
show's technical advisor who i've known
for years asked me if i would drive i
said sure and that's pretty much how it
all went down after a half dozen
episodes co-creator derek hoss told
ferraris he was going to start writing
lines for him and that technical advisor
who got ferraris into the spotlight that
was steve chicarotis a chicago
firefighter who's also appeared in more
than 20 episodes of chicago fire along
with helping to write and serving as an
associate producer sophia bush was one
of the main stars of chicago pd at its
beginning in 2014
the most recognizable member of the cast
thanks to her time on the hit teen soap
one tree hill bush portrayed the
complicated aaron lindsay a former
juvenile offender who becomes a police
informant before working her way up to
chicago police detective
at the end of the fourth season of
chicago pd though detective lindsay
abruptly left her hard-won position
accepting a spot with the fbi's
counterterrorism squad in new york city
so as to shield her mother the subject
of a murder investigation in reality
bush's character was written out because
the actor had decided to leave chicago
pd
the reason as she told dax shepard's
armchair expert pondcast bush found the
show's working conditions to be
deplorable
it was a consistent onslaught barrage of
abusive behavior bush said that her body
began breaking down because of the
constant stress
at first producers wouldn't let bush out
of her contract so she played hardball
threatening to sue to get out of it or
go public with her criticisms in a new
york times op-ed
and that seemed to do the trick
oliver flatt is among the most acclaimed
american actors of his generation lauded
for performances on the small screen big
screen and broadway he's been nominated
for four emmy awards he received various
accolades for his appearances in films
like frost nixon and please gif and he
was a tony award nominee in 2006 for the
play shining city and yet the thing for
which he's arguably best known is
chicago met so how did platt wind up
doing network tv
it's all owing to his connection with
one chicago architect dick wolf
solidified over another tv show that
didn't succeed platt told the hollywood
reporter dick and i did another show
together way back in 2000 dick and i
formed a very real friendship and i have
a tremendous respect for dick as a
producer
platt said he was particularly
interested to explore mental health in
the er there's no no x-ray for
anxiety right and sort of adding that
element into this environment was to be
an interesting interesting character to
explore while all the chicago shows can
stand on their own nbc lumps the
connected series together and airs them
in succession on chicago wednesdays
that's one full night of shows and it
would seem about as much chicago drama
that the marketplace can hold or
audiences can tolerate
on march 1 2017 nbc debuted chicago
justice the fourth entry in producer
dick wolf's one chicago saga about windy
city public servants and first
responders the courtroom drama bore some
similarities to the order portion of
wolf's long-running law and order as
well as some connections
lead character and prosecutor peter
stone was the son of law order attorney
ben stone
chicago justice settled into its run as
a mid-season replacement after
premiering as the tail end of a
three-show crossover with chicago fire
and chicago pd despite its link to those
hit series chicago justice was one
chicago series too many after just 13
episodes were met with much lower
ratings than those of its sister series
nbc sent chicago justice away
once one chicago producers decide to
make a spin-off they generally do so
efficiently but chicago med's rollout
was complicated and rushed the april
2015 chicago fire installment i am the
apocalypse introduced chicago med's
premise and the standalone show
premiered just seven months later it was
actually set to debut in early 2016 but
then nbc fast tracked it for a fall
debut after the medical drama
heartbreaker was suddenly postponed due
to the pregnancy of star melissa george
then in august med star lori holden
abruptly quit the show citing family
reasons days later and mere weeks before
filming was set to begin showrunner
andrew detman left over creative clashes
with production company universal
television given all these hurdles it's
a miracle the show became the hit it is
one day in december 2012
local chicago program wgn morning news
carried a harrowing and startling story
about a plane crash within city limits
with overhead footage obtained by its
helicopter team wgn aired video of the
wreckage depicting a small downed plane
on the corner of chicago's 29th street
and martin luther king drive also
reporting that roads around the site of
the accident had been closed to traffic
a tragedy for sure but it turned out to
have a happy ending for everyone except
journalists a few moments after
delivering the news of the plane crash
anchors larry potash and robin
baumgarten issued an update the plane
crash wasn't a real crash at all merely
a simulated one as it turns out it was a
setup for a scene in chicago fire which
had only just recently begun shooting
its first season in the windy city
and irate baumgarden said on the air
they might want to tell the news folks
when they're doing this and shutting
down king drive are you kidding me
potash then helpfully added just to be
clear the other stories in that news
block were real
just the last one not so much people
contain multitudes and that certainly
held true for chicago pd's sean roman
at the end of chicago pd's third season
it looked like the hot-headed roman was
a goner after he was shot in the line of
duty however he somehow survived only to
disappear from the show anyway after
choosing to quit the force and move away
to san diego rather than be relegated to
semi-active police duty so why did the
sudden departure happen
actually it was more or less planned
right from the beginning of the series
series creator dick wolf really wanted
actor brian garrity on the show but
garrity was unsure about signing the
seven year contract that is typical for
stars of shows like chicago pd so to
accommodate garrity wolfe instead agreed
to allow garrity to sign a year-to-year
deal so he could quote leave the show
when he felt it was time to move on
nbc gives over a lot of its prime time
schedule each week of the regular season
to dick wolf's one chicago franchise
with an entire night of programming
that's a substantial commitment to a
franchise that hasn't always proven to
be a popular or profitable endeavor
despite how procedural shows are usually
a safe bet for networks witness the
success of ncis and law and order shows
none of the three exton chicago series
were hits right out of the gate even the
ones that were launched on the backs of
previous chicago shows that had evolved
into hits chicago fire debuted in fall
2012 and it finished its first season as
only the 51st most watched show on
network tv nbc renewed it and used it to
launch the police-centered spin-off
chicago pd in january 2014 which
finished its first season at number 61.
chicago med did a little better in its
inaugural season finishing at number 37
in the 2015-16 television season but nbc
stuck with the shows letting the cast
and creative staff find their voice and
allowing time for an audience to build
it worked in the
2019-2020 season all three parts of one
chicago ranked near the top of the
nielsen tv ratings chicago fire came in
at number seven followed by chicago pd
and chicago med tied at number 10. in
terms of total average viewers one
chicago draws more people than cbs's
multi-programmed ncis juggernaut the
2020 deaths of george floyd and brianna
taylor at the hands of police officers
in minnesota and kentucky set off an
international wave of civil rights
protests not seen in the u.s since the
1960s while americans publicly and
privately grappled with questions of
systemic racism law enforcement
overreach and police brutality it left
the entertainment industry in a strange
place
long the hallmark of television programs
that celebrated or glorified police
suddenly felt dated at best and
totalitarian at worst law enforcement
reality shows live pv and cops were
quickly cancelled and several cast
members both past and present of nbc's
law enforcement heavy one chicago
franchise publicly supported police
reform in the black lives matter
movement those actors may have
ultimately forced the hand of their
bosses to address the issues on their
purportedly gritty realistic and ripped
from the headlines tv series also
spurring action civil rights advocacy
group color of change co-authored a 2020
study called normalizing injustice which
argue that tv shows chicago pd in
particular normalize police misbehavior
so in september 2020 nicole ari parker
joined the cast of chicago pd as deputy
superintendent samantha miller a police
reform advocate who comes to chicago to
assist voight and his team follows
strict new police protocols the days of
playing god are over
the quicker you understand that the
better
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv personalities are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you